do not mess with me okay sounds good
what are you doing i don't know what
you're talking about i've sponsored my
forehead oh look good
why are you licking my forehead i'm not
meet my eyeline jim
i just had a couple of notes let me grab
a pen and
damn it
ah just when we were
just when we were getting going
hey dwight
what are you doing
what those are my keys good luck
jim damn it no
jim let me out
jim let
the light green
jim halpert let me out who is this all
right here's the thing okay
you just keep talking to her if you hit
a stall you have a perfect fallback
what's that you buy a purse i don't want
a purse purses are for girls dwight
that's not necessarily true okay do you
read gq no okay i do they're like mini
briefcases all right lots of guys have
them jim for instance has a huge tell
when he gets a good hand
he coughs
[Applause]
it's the weirdest thing every time i
cough he folds uh someone forged medical
information and that is a felony okay
whoa
all right cause that's a pretty intense
accusation how do you know that they're
fake uh
leprosy
flesh eating bacteria
hot dog fingers
uh pam and i would sometimes hum the
same high-pitched note and try to get
dwight to make an appointment with an
ear doctor you're just agreeing with him
because he's wearing a tux don't you see
what he's doing here last week dwight
sent out a memo about the dress code so
this is me showing him that i'm taking
it very seriously
oh turns out that stanley is quite the
comedy fan
but not everything makes him laugh
what the heck is going on the stock
price is it plummeting are you going to
get control of the message or do i have
to send in someone who understands the
name i didn't have to hear more on page
uh excuse me
okay i didn't actually major in public
speaking but i did download speeches
from some of history's famous dictators
like this one
originally given by benito mussolini
okay look i know you're giving this
speech on your own but i wrote up a few
talking points for you to take a look at
took a little nap right next to jim's
desk i feel so good right now mmm
cookies
what's everyone staring at
oh man i was supposed to tell dwight
something
dwight is special
but i don't believe that his talents are
being used in this office
so pam and i have put his resume on
monster.com google
craigslist
hello dwight schrute
one thing
um but tomorrow you mean saturday right
today is
thursday here
over here it's okay
dwight
down white right
man i wish i was there to see his face
when he gets to the end and finds the
fake grail
no grail you don't remember i don't you
expect me to believe that you're
starting a rebellion
nope social club god i hate when
everybody calls us a rebellion
quick phone call from you guys keep
going eight
nine hello
ken
we got it
hey i have a question who do you think
is really the best salesman in this
office
stupid question obviously mr james
halpert
so let's just say that dwight has come
at you with the throat punch now how
would you dwight defend against it easy
allow me to demonstrate
i am attacking myself with a throat
punch here it comes
block
grasp wrist as such and what if he comes
at you with the other hand because he
does have two
good points second throat punch
absorb the blow
groin punch
hip block elbow to the gut i know
exactly what to do great
this is gonna be perfect okay centrally
located perfect cover i can hear and see
everything
good
i forged his desk phone to mine
oh hello mutter good news i've married
telfotter
such a nice woman
this is humongous i am not a security
threat and my middle name is kurt not
fart what did i write
oh wait a minute so you're gonna time me
every time i yawn
that's absurd
really
oh hey look monkey knows how to use a
stopwatch everybody he's ty
uh how much is that
it's only 25 bucks wow
um okay
jim what's up buddy this is not funny
why is my stuff in here wow that's weird
ooh dollar for stapler that's pretty
good yeah well i'm not paying for my own
stuff okay i know you did this because
you're friends with the vending machine
guy oh steve yeah steve what do i want
what do i want
oh
pencil cup you can't do that
why not
safety violation i could fall and pierce
an organ
we'll see
i got 500 feet of red wire at a flea
market up by delmore high school
20 bucks for the whole spool
crazy what a deal
not sure
just became self-aware the bat i mean i
know i felt it bite me but look there's
no mark
i feel so
tingly
so strangely powerful
oh well
louder son bonnicker our prices have
never been lower
that is totally inappropriate in our
very limited free time and with our very
limited budget we went and got a nanny
and then we went out and took a class on
a very outmoded and very unnecessary
form of communication just so we could
talk about you
in front of you
yep
last week i may have gone too far
damn it jim
damn it
okay hold on hold on judge is in session
what is the problem here
you put my stuff in jello again at 8 a.m
today someone poisons the coffee do not
drink the coffee more instructions will
follow
cordially future dwight
you'll thank me later if i can skin a
mule deer in less than 10 minutes i
ought to be able to cut my
oh no no no no
it wasn't me
we gotta find the wanda at that alcohol
club oh
god
question
what kind of bear is best
that's a ridiculous question false black
bear well that's debatable there are
basically two schools of thought fact
bears eat beets
bears
beets
battlestar galactica bears do not
what is going on what are you doing
dwight wanna knock him okay
halton sure
been twice
what are you doing
all right
warmer hot red hot hot
very hot
dwight schrute who are you
who am i
i'm jim we've been working together for
12 years
we're joked white
you're not jim jim's not asian
you seriously never noticed hey hats off
to you for not seeing race
i can't be there for you
i'm sorry
jim
i just
really wish there was something i could
do
michael
i can't believe you came
that's what she said
[Laughter]
this prank ever
you